on a deux minutes d'une hachette bomba
toutes les preuves et sont là dedans
pour arroser les grands médias suivent
et ce un mois à peine 20 longueurs ça va
être rochina bah c'est pas mal on te des
conflits
lancé sur le web
ça va être repris partout je te le dis
je me sens un droit fort il devrait être
pro
des centaines de milliers de personnes
ont été exposées
ça fait 30 ans qu'il existe médoc
réveillez vous les gars
disant prendre certaines choses en
charge imagine on s'est vraiment qu'ils
vont faire ça pour des gens comme moi
oui la guerre aux méchins la beauce et
ça en attendant c'est lui qui me font
bouffer mais sans financement pas de
recherches possibles
tu l'as cherché pour le service des
malades pourquoi force cultive
taillé en pièces pas de panique avoir
une gueule pour ça suffit alors
maintenant tu vas prendre ta vie tu es
beaucoup plaint madame irène frachon
on va voir comment les perdre
c'est fini j'ai parlé ici pour le gênant
propos reviendra jamais complètement si
t'as pas été au bout
il n'y a pas de vrai combat sans peur
tous les vrais résistants ont peur et se
croit
non
moi je vous pose la question à laquelle
votre livre répond jamais combien de
morts
de vrais résultats surprenants
posez-vous d'abord la question et si
c'était vrai